hello reject nation Greg Alva here and
tear Ericsson here Tara Ericsson is with
me today guys Alexa turn off heartbreak
is her new live show check it out a lot
of laughs to be had wrote it stars in it
and it's gonna be studio C on Santa
Monica Boulevard I got tickets for
opening night you guys can come by and
say hi she has several other shows
throughout June please go check out the
link in the description box use the
promo code real rejects five bucks off
that really helps because the tickets
are already $150 so you guys only spent
a hundred 45 145 easy-peasy twenty
minutes show no it's like an hour-long
show and the tickets are pretty cheap
actually she I know you guys are
struggling but I put thousands into it
so come on come check it out you watch
the first episode of Cobra Kai and now
she's your day to watch the second
episode I'm so excited you guys have no
idea I actually really liked it
iris surprise I'm like surprised how
funny and and cool and there's like some
build-up what yes it's well developed so
I'm excited to see how the rest of the
show progresses we only watch the pilot
so let's see
[Music]
oh okay you kill one guy that's writes
his episodes of star
[Music]
that's a good editing that's that's
great editing spoken to is that
understood yes all right you ready to
begin your training
yes
strike first never wait for the enemy to
attack okay like putting on a party you
see a hot babe yeah you'd a wait for
some other guy to go talk to her first
do you I mean I've never been to a party
so oh right if you're not aggressive huh
and you're being a [ __ ] and you don't
want to be a person you won't have balls
don't you think you're doing the latter
gender I see no what the hell are you
talking about big work my guidance
counselor you're gonna listen to me is
that understood yes good you you a
customer here oh no that's just an
illegal I picked up this morning he's
helping me set up my job this place is
up 200 man so I have to do all this crap
no lay jabs I'm gonna shoot some hoops
on when your prize I'm thirsty great
there's a bar right over there
[Music]
damn feet echod sodas not a good idea
I killed the visit club like this when I
was his age what do you say we let
Anthony play with this thing you not
gonna come to him he'll add in a hottie
yeah you sure did guy from my high
school whose car I just fixed for free
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
his life is not all it's made out to be
people sure is but everyone knows you're
Guns and Roses oh no God sir roses are
have kids talk I banging is such a
strong my god yeah he's doing bad
parenting who cares about his kid I just
don't want to turn you into one of these
privileged Encino birds yeah freakin
Encino hate dad I've never tried moving
there it's the worst Oh Boris Oh
that looks easy it's here I never hear
defense beware the spinning
my karate teacher did the same thing for
me spinning husband a little bit right
just words not even officially dating
they're just that's my girl the girl my
stay here tables really blowing up right
now I can put you on the waitlist but
it's probably next semester at the
earliest
okay no I'm kidding Mean Girls cliche
storytelling oh [ __ ] strike first
now something's gonna interrupt him
[Music]
oh you beat him up in the first episode
right damn yes that's where the pumps go
strike here your buddies no strike here
you break his teeth strike here you
could severely damage his trachea
obviously that's only for extreme
situations father but you're supposed to
call his mom called her she's not
picking up
all right what do you do this time we
found him with Molly there's some
chickies hooking up with it's an illegal
drug mr. Moore ah I put my kid on the
phone I've never done Molly it did not
feel amazing doing drugs no no you're
doing it all wrong
what do you want those kids at school to
keep dumping [ __ ] on your head you know
other girls to think you're wangus
daughter
oh you have a picture in your mind it's
a traumatic moment yeah
you have physics oh my god I hate him
this is fresh tradition I picked up from
the Japanese market this morning what
are you Paris from there's something
going on at home okay
some guy in a mini-mall you just jumped
me and my friends good build-up Wow
some things never change yeah what are
you talking about
I heard you beat up a bunch of teenagers
in that parking lot out there I kicked
the [ __ ] out of a bunch of [ __ ] who
deserved it Oh Johnny Laurens calling
someone else an [ __ ] that's Richmond
yeah what's that supposed to mean
look I'm not here to rehash the past so
this whole show is about for my
daughter's friends nice company she
keeps those friends of hers from whaling
on a kid half their size and maybe you
don't know your daughter as well as you
think you do get your house in order
LaRussa Oh
oh you and I miss you know I don't
I'm right here man
[Music]
yeah I got some nipple chills right now
[Music]
haven't told you the third listen
whoa he really builds the schools wow
what an episode man only junk I really
like the show I love the show it's this
like amazing surprising blend that has
its like nostalgia of course but it has
like a great blend of comedy and drama
and intense moments these other elements
that I wasn't expecting when I first
heard about this show I thought it would
just be like some silly and nostalgia
fest right and then I'm watching and
they just made a real show they made a
real continuation of a series would
fully fleshed-out characters I love how
Danny Larusso you know like the first
episode he kind of seems like a snob
kind of douchey yeah in this episode you
see you know he's still the same
good-hearted guy it's just we were
seeing Danny Larusso through Johnny
Lawrence's perspective right so he seems
douchey but when you just see Danny
Larusso here like oh he's actually
doesn't have his life all in order I
mean he's grown distant from his
daughter he's gotta keep his family
intact they've kind of grown up like
I'll spoiled and unappreciative I think
he's a really charming character and
he's probably the character we all came
back for but I find it funny how the one
that is the most gravitated towards his
Johnny Lawrence for sure yeah he's got
an [ __ ] personality he's snobby but
you can see that there's a side of him
that is caring yeah I mean he's had
underlying issues which they built up
with all these like flashbacks of like
he's had a hard-knock life
yeah and I kids who kind of grow up in
that environment they kind of like tend
to be bullies punks whatever he goes
into adult you end up like we assumed
you would but he's trying to fight
against it you know he has this kid who
he's not close with at all as something
has no relationship with him I like this
father-son bonding relationship he's
developing with
I forget the one kid's name I was
looking dude in the Karate Kid who's
actually in class
he's a main character I like him I like
him a lot too
I like the flip they've done with what
we know of the Karate Kid because Danny
Larusso was the one who had mr. Miyagi
and was trained in Cobra Kai was viewed
as his enemy now Cobra Kai's a center of
attention for the dojo they're seeing
him mentor a kid now you're seeing the
good that's coming out of that it's like
out of Cobra Kai yeah yeah yeah there's
some dangerous lethal things that come
from it but I like the teaser leading to
like no there's gonna be a bunch of kids
were gonna be joining karate he's gonna
be coming back a bit more of an [ __ ]
or is he gonna be like Daniel Larusso
who just learned to defend himself
I could see him becoming like a tough
dick yeah like a tough douche yeah yeah
I would like to see that because I feel
like the cliche router's he would just
become a guy who's good at defending
himself and he's still the nice guy at
heart I would kind of like to see him
evolve into a guy who's a little bit
douchey yeah be unique be really got
some cliche setup so I think he's only
gonna do that you can evolve to be a
little bit douchey went over the girl
keeps the girl turns back to just being
chill you think so yeah yeah good guy
except listen these kids in this they
need to get get it together we got
bullies we got girls hitting cars her
friends the Russos daughter her friends
are the worst number one you got to cut
those bees out of your life okay it's
getting 20 in there but also those guys
at the lunch table that he sits with the
nerd alert table they're my favorite
great comedian timing the guy who's
talking he's Sakai every station
sarcastic I loved all of his dialogue it
was hilarious
yeah I love those two characters great
setup exactly Mean Girls give each other
hands around school it's interesting
because it seemed like in the first
radhika cobra kai took in guys who were
already bullies and like tough and it
seems like in this show Cobra Kai is
gonna be taken in nerds underdog because
I feel like yeah the guy with the lip
and the other nerd alert they're all
gonna be in Cobra Kai yeah listen you
don't
you're gonna rise those birds are gonna
rise I'm excited for this journal
arising via Cobra Kai I am into it
sign me up they're actually honoring
what karate is like the essence of
correct you got the Cobra Kai style then
you get the mr. Miyagi style but it's
not like making fun of karate no if I
thought it really invested yeah it's
like Gregory it's here and here but
mainly here not there no no not here you
miss the note here here not there and
I'm pointing at his stomach to be
correct don't worry the cameras not down
there but here and here is where karate
is at and when they say it I didn't
laughs I was like wow you know it is
deep and heart brain and heart I want
that car once the TransAm can somebody
just yeah just message me okay get on my
youtube channel leave me a little
comment I got a TransAm just like that
I'm willing to give it to you for almost
free and then we'll be friends forever
I'm into it are you not into the car and
you know you're not excited to the car
you're not into it what tell me what are
we gonna say we he's got thoughts
brewing in here Gregory out he's gonna
never in the moment thoughts are going
he's at the moment every word I'm
speaking and he's going what am i what
am I gonna say hi this guy he leaves me
out hanging hanging in the dust me me
and my words
we're over here well he's flying through
the sky with his words and then it's
just I don't know he runs into my words
cuz I'm dust and he's the bird didn't I
put you as a bird in a metaphor so he
flying around and I'm Dustin with my
thoughts and then he just flies right
through my guest
I like the build-up between Danny
Larusso parties now we're back cuz it's
got an insight they're building it up so
the tension is so well done it gets you
excited I want to come back like what
are they gonna battle each other again
and I love the direction of where he was
standing there's a big black square in
the middle of his dojo room and he came
right up to that [ __ ] that rematch
right yeah it's a good stage picture I
was kind of curious though they kind of
left out some things they could have
said yes Johnny Lawrence didn't like
yeah your daughter totally crashing in
my car exactly I thought he was gonna
say yeah I showed up they said beating
on some kid they're like they attacked
him further things he left out that he
couldn't see that builds him up to be a
little bit nicer of a guy to maybe in
the back of his head he doesn't really
want to screw over larusso's like give
him all this info that he's just like
listen man I'm gonna give you a
minimalist info yeah because I don't
want to totally screw you over cuz I
don't think it's in his heart to do that
but he still like once a reason he wants
to provoke him and he's gotta save some
stop you gotta save some stuff for
burners later
save it save his kid Lawrence's kid
pretty boy pretty boy also messed up cuz
his dad's not around here's what's gonna
happen dad is becoming Cobra Kai King
the kids gonna show up and go what's
this you got a business now dad and then
he's gonna be like yes I'm so sorry I
didn't teach you here and here but now
you're gonna be a good boy cuz I'm gonna
here and here he's gonna teach him all
this stuff the here and here you see
what I'm going for here so then he's
gonna become a good dad out of Cobra Kai
it's all gonna work out I know that
everybody back there you guys like what
about his child his child left behind'
he's struggling at school and he's doing
Molly but like it's no stress because
Cobra Kai he's gonna he's gonna get it
back in his groove back in his heart
gonna be Cobra Kai King and he's gonna
save the son and then he's gonna be good
dad it's gonna be I already wrote the
whole story you're welcome
this in case I needed to help writing
the next season I'm here my name is Tara
Eriksen I'm available you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell
Tara Ericsson is on YouTube I'm on
YouTube too you can look me up occur up
reactions true the reenactments hey
lucky Alexa turn off heartbreak